[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're taking a look at the first tablet
running android 4.0.3 ice cream sandwich
the first quad core mobile device today
we're taking a look at our full review
of the asus transformer prime first of
all this thing features probably the
best build quality of any tablet on the
market to date it has a spun metal
finish on the back where it houses that
8 megapixel camera and a flash and has a
solid array of ports from the volume
rocker the mini hdmi port the micro sd
card slot and the power button up top
along with that microphone and on the
other side the 3.5 millimeter headphone
jack with the very impressive speaker
which i'll detail in a second and all of
that comes in a package just 8.3
millimeters thin which is thinner than
even the samsung galaxy nexus but don't
let those specs fool you it may be
really thin and really light but it
feels really good in the hand just
messing around with it maybe in a store
or something you'll probably be able to
tell and with build quality like that it
makes it ideal for just lounging back
and watching movies or just youtube
videos on that 10.1 inch 1280x800 super
lcd display and when i say super lcd
that's not only a complement to the
quality and the viewing angles but the
thing also gets really bright like 600
nits bright like most computer monitors
only go up to 300 or 350 nits so you can
read this thing in sunlight unlike some
other tablets out there
but yeah this has an excellent display
so of course what we love about the
transformer prime is the tegra 3 chip
that powers this thing along with liquid
smoothness and fluidity as you can see
it's a quad core chip but it has a fifth
core running at a slightly lighter clock
speed of 500 megahertz to take core of
stuff like in the background like
swiping between home screens and just
running background tasks and little
stuff like this and this actually saves
battery life a lot i get great battery
life because it offsets all the stuff
that would normally be on the 1.3
gigahertz quad-core chip for the more
demanding stuff so android 4.0 is just
like
like
i mean i can't even describe how good it
is it's like if google hired me to find
something wrong with ice cream sandwich
i i'd be fired it's it's amazing it's
beautiful everything right from the
design right down to the font the roboto
font is absolutely well executed so
props to google for android 4.0 doing a
really good job with this one now just
as a side note if you are running an
android 4.0 device go ahead go to your
settings go down to developer settings
and click ok and enable force gpu
rendering this is what's giving me the
liquid smooth performance with the apps
that aren't ics enabled yet so stuff
like twika
you can go through really smooth
scrolling stuff like spotify all apps
for phones work amazingly well and if
you enable this on your 4.0 smartphone
you're also going to get really smooth
performance in a lot of apps now
something i've been asked a lot about
was the browser performance on the
transformer prime and it's been a mixed
bag sometimes it looks at the website
you're visiting it says meh you know
this is a light website and i don't have
to put a lot of horsepower into it so it
doesn't and you might find yourself on
the single core for light stuff but you
might get to a heavy website like this
and pinching and scrolling might become
more difficult so you need to trust that
that quad core power is going to kick in
for those bigger websites and the more
heavy tasks and stuff so i found the
easiest way to get good performance uh
was to have multiple tabs open but
generally the stock browser was pretty
good there's some nice features in it
from ice cream sandwich and it handles
adobe flash just fine so it gives a
pretty nice overall great web experience
now i've also gotten more involved with
gaming on the transformer prime you
thought i was going to open angry birds
didn't you no but but this
holy buns this is insane absolutely
ridiculous it blew my mind this tegra 3
really shines here like nothing integra
2 could ever cover in fact this is one
of the one times i wish i still had my
zoom so i could compare and show you
guys just how much slower it was playing
these same games in a lower quality i'm
telling you the video doesn't even do it
justice rich high definition graphics
and fast response times to movement and
touch are like nothing i have ever seen
before freaking props to nvidia for this
one it sounds like they paid me to say
that
i mean yeah they probably should have
actually but seriously guys look at it
just look at it it's beautiful
uh and even you can see the water
splashing on the game in this in the
screen is just absolutely beautiful
so you can definitely expect to get
awesome gaming performance and a great
experience from gaming on the
transformer prime hands down the best
android gaming tablet i promise in fact
let's wait a sec let's let's go over
this bump in the water here
oh yeah look at the water that's
splashed up on the screen that is just
awesome riptide gp by the way is the
name of the game if you want to check it
out so now you know the transformer
prime's got it all covered it has an
office suite for businessmen and it's
got a ton of great games in the android
market for leisure the ever-growing
android market i hope to get my hands on
the docs soon to take a detailed look at
that but until then this is the
transformer prime you know it's had a
few quirks like people complaining about
wi-fi strength and gps lock the gps
issue was fixed with a recent firmware
update while the wi-fi issue while it's
never cut out on me has always been a
tad little bit weaker because of the
metal body
and the speaker the speaker it's like
someone at asus thought hey dude what's
the most inconvenient place we can
possibly put a speaker right here where
they hold the tablet right right where
they put their hand okay that's exactly
where we'll put it
but honestly the speaker has a really
good quality that makes up for it and
it's pretty loud so overall really this
is the best tablet money can buy so if
you've got 500 bucks sitting on the
monitor underneath you're watching this
video on
you should hand that to me right now
or go go pick up a 32 gig wi-fi
transformer prime it's available in
either gray or gold
hey thanks for watching this full review
and if you enjoyed it please go ahead
and give it a thumbs up i really do
appreciate the rating
and thanks for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in a bit
peace
[Music]
you